the big problem that most people have  when they are starting their business is  that they are in the selling business  not in the reorder business they don't  have recurring Revenue they have  one-time sales so when you see these  merch drops and these things where  people are just selling crap and they  get the one-time purchase and no one  buys again the reason they can't make  money is because they have no  compounding vehicle what that means is  that if I sell somebody today I want to  get credit for that person that I sold  today in a year because what happens is  if you don't have that then you're  always selling for tomorrow you're  always selling for the paycheck this  month you're always selling to pay rent  rather than benefiting from a sale you  made 10 years ago and having that person  still pay you today because the thing is  that you need to harness time the people  who understand wealth understand time